en noviembre del 2019 en pleno
enfrentamiento con la política
internacional unilateral de donald trump
el presidente macrón declaraba que la
alianza del atlántico norte estaba con
muerte cerebral pero el conflicto entre
rusia y ucrania le ha llevado a
reconsiderar estas declaraciones cuatro
candidatos entre ellos el mandatario
apoya la permanencia de francia en la
otan macrón considera que la guerra le
ha dado nuevamente la claridad
estratégica de sus orígenes en un
eventual segundo mandato propone un
cuartel general europeo cinco candidatos
piden por su parte seguir en la alianza
pero no en el comando integrado que es
el que fija las estrategias militares
les hace aplicar en el terreno poniendo
a disposición soldados en muchos el caso
de marín le pedís para quien eso es
incompatible con el estatus de potencia
soberana de francia finalmente tres
candidatos están por la salida total de
la alianza como la izquierdista natal y
hasta un luchador era para quienes la
política imperialista de la otan platea
puesto ucrania en el centro de los
enfrentamientos
la tierra en ucrania y el papel de
francia en el conflicto dividen también
a los candidatos cinco de ellos proponen
seguir enviando armas y sancionando al
entorno de vladimir putin es el caso de
la candidata del partido derecho a los
republicanos balear y pcs para quien se
deben restringir las compras de
hidrocarburos rusos y acoger refugiados
ucranianos pero hay también tres
candidatos que prefieren que ucrania no
integre la otan y se mantenga neutral
para no provocar la molestia rusa es el
caso del polemista eric se move que
además propone mantener la tradición
francesa del diálogo con moscú
cuatro candidatos están en cambio por
una salida pacífica el conflicto ya sea
por mediación de la onu o como el líder
anticapitalista frenando las
exportaciones de armas francesas y
desarmando al país
la unión europea es también tema de
divisiones pero menos que en elecciones
anteriores cinco candidatos son pro
europeos entre ellos el presidente macro
que aboga por una europa soberana que
pese sobre el curso del mundo sin
embargo algunos como el ecologista
hallado europeístas quieren terminar con
la regla del límite al déficit público
del 3% que generó la crisis de la deuda
años atrás entre los dos candidatos que
defienden una salida de france de la
unión europea está natalia acto quien
propone una europa sin fronteras o mejor
dicho unos estados socialistas de europa
donde todos puedan moverse libremente
otros cinco candidatos si bien no están
por la salida del bloque proponen una
primacía del derecho nacional sobre el
comunitario es el caso de marín de penn
y ya nos quiere salir del bloque pero sí
que toda nueva ley nacional vive sobre
el derecho europeo existente pese a la
guerra las relaciones internacionales
siguen estando en el último lugar de las
preocupaciones de los franceses según
una última encuesta y es que justamente
a raíz del conflicto otros temas como la
salud las jubilaciones y el poder
adquisitivo se han vuelto prioritarios